- [Mark] Okay Juan,
Juan, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Juan] Well, I was born in Mexico.
- [Mark] Oh really?
- [Juan] Yeah.
- [Mark] You came to the USA at what age?
- [Juan] At 11, 11 years old.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
- My family,
my mom and dad came here to
the United States maybe about,
a year before.
They wanted to try if it worked out,
they left us over there in Mexico,
and in less than a year,
they brought us over.
- [Mark] Then you, the
whole family was here?
- The whole family.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- My childhood was, it was good no--
- [Mark] No abuse, no crazy?
- No abuse, no no.
We were poor but still I mean...
- [Mark] Yeah.
- We were poor.
We were poor like,
they would feed us only
what they could afford,
no meat, no, just the simplest
food that they could afford.
- [Mark] Oh really?
- Yeah.
I got three sisters, and the only boy.
- [Mark] You're the only boy?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What have you done for work?
- Work?
Here?
Well, I did go to school here.
I did graduate from high school.
- [Mark] Okay.
- Didn't go to college
but I mean, for work
I started working
at a manufacturing place for 16 years.
- [Mark] Okay.
- 16.
Then during 2005, Hurricane Katrina,
I wanted to try construction,
so that was my chance to work construction
and ever since I've been
working construction.
- [Mark] Oh so you work
in construction now?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Excellent.
Are you married?
- I was married for 16 years.
- [Mark] Now you're divorced?
- Divorced.
- [Mark] Do you have children?
- I have one, just one.
- [Mark] How old is your son or daughter?
- He's 15.
- [Mark] Son?
- Yeah son, 15 year old.
- [Mark] So you like to, you
come down to Skid Row sometimes
and pick up some of the
girls that are here?
- Yes, cause I'm divorced,
I feel lonely sometimes. (chuckles)
So I come and pick up one girl.
- [Mark] How often do you come by?
- Not very often.
I used to often, but not no more.
- [Mark] Yeah?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Where would you go?
Into your car or you go to
hotel or what do you do?
- In the car most of the times,
or depending on how it is,
take them home or motel.
- [Mark] Yeah.
What does this cost you typically?
- At first, you kinda get addicted to,
it's kinda like an addiction, I guess.
- [Mark] Yeah, I've heard
that from a lot of guys.
- It's like,
it was often before.
Like, too often.
- [Mark] (chuckling) Too often?
- It's something,
it's hard to get rid of the craving.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- It's not so much the feeling,
it's a craving, you get addicted to it.
I don't do it often now.
- [Mark] You cut back?
- I cut back.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You gotta, I guess you gotta
train your brain to not to.
(laughing)
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You know not to.
- [Mark] Have you ever been robbed or?
- Oh yeah.
- [Mark] How does that happen?
- They always ask for money up front,
you give them the money
next thing you know,
they're gone.(chuckles)
- [Mark] With your wallet?
- Not my wallet that hasn't happened.
- [Mark] Oh, just the money?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Oh I see.
- Just the money.
- [Mark] There's no transaction.
They just they took your
money and they left?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Ah.
- Yeah, I mean.
- [Mark] Have you ever
been arrested for this?
- Once.
- [Mark] One time?
- One time.
Yeah, one.
They didn't prosecute me
or anything like that.
It was,
the cops kind of made a,
how do you say?
They made a, they were doing a...
I'm stuck.
Usually when I'm nervous I get stuck.
- [Mark] Yeah but they
were trying to arrest
a lot of people doing this?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- This wild girl came over,
I was parked and asked
me if I wanna have sex
and I didn't say anything.
So, next thing you know
I got cops back on me,
I wasn't driving or anything.
So they took me in for that.
They didn't,
no charges were filed
or anything like that,
but it was maybe that's why I cut back.
(both laughing)
- [Mark] Oh that'll do it.
- That will do it, right?
- [Mark] I think that's how
(chuckles) law enforcement
is supposed to work.
- Yeah.
They didn't do anything.
- [Mark] Yeah but it got you to cut back.
- Yeah, that's,
no more like--
- [Mark] Do you think doing this,
kinda stops you from having a relationship
with somebody who's not a prostitute?
- It kinda
- [Mark] Does it make that less likely it?
- It kinda,
it does kinda affect,
like in a relationship,
if you wanna find somebody
that's worthy of a relationship,
it's hard 'cause, why would
you go through all that trouble
of meeting somebody and like,
when there's girls out here,
you just pay 'em and that's it?
You don't have to put
up with their attitude.
You don't have to, when you're married.
To me I don't feel like,
I don't wanna be going
through that marriage thing
and all that,
so it's easier for me to just come in.
- [Mark] Yeah, this is a
good alternative for you.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you remember
your first time doing this?
- My first time, it was a long time ago.
- [Mark] Were you married?
- I wasn't married.
- [Mark] Is it after you were married?
- No.
- [Mark] Or before?
- It was before I was married.
- [Mark] What was that first time like?
- The first time it was,
it was kinda, I was,
actually, I had never had sex before,
so it was my first time.
- [Mark] Oh, really?
(Juan laughs)
Wow.
- Yeah it was my first time
and I guess it wasn't a
good experience, at all.
- [Mark] (chuckles) No?
- You know?
It wasn't.
It's like trying to learn how to drive.
- [Mark] Oh really? (laughs)
- 'Cause it was trying to
learn how to drive by yourself.
(both laughing)
You are scared,
you wanna do it, like you wanna learn,
but it's kinda like 10 ways.
- [Mark] How old were you?
- I was, oh
I believe I was somewhere in
my 19, somewhere around there.
I was already old.
- [Mark] Do you ever think
you could fall in love
with one of these ladies?
- It's a possibility.
- [Mark] Yeah?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Then you'd
probably have to save them,
get them off drugs and
all the, other things.
'Cause it's pretty much,
all of them are probably
playing around drugs.
- Yeah, all of them, most of them.
- [Mark] They're nice girls,
but they're addicted
to drugs and that's...
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That'll be a problem eventually,
at some point.
- Oh yeah.
I guess, it would take a lot
to get them off the drugs.
- [Mark] Yeah that's hard.
- A lot.
- [Mark] Yeah, as much
as you might want it,
they have to want it, so.(sighs)
- Yeah, it would take
more than the feeling,
'cause the feeling of what
they have for the drug,
is greater than the one
that would feel here.
- [Mark] You would need to motivate them
to wanna do it for themselves.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you frequent the same ladies
rather than getting
different ones every time?
- No I stick to the same one.
- [Mark] How many different
ones do you visit?
- Here?
Four maybe three.
- [Mark] Do you go to other
neighborhoods too, for this?
- No.
- [Mark] Just here?
- Just here.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I already know 'em so.
- [Mark] Are you typically
just doing oral sex?
- No, I do...
- [Mark] You have
intercourse and everything?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] yeah
- Always, with protection though.
- [Mark] Yeah, you always use a condom?
- Yes, always.
There's no exception for it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Yeah there's too many.
- Yeah there's too many
things going on
- [Mark] Dangerous things
out there.
- Yup,
too many.
- [Mark] Do you ever find
you have to use alcohol or drugs to?
- I used to be like an alcoholic.
When I was married,
when you were having trouble with the...
you start drinking,
it makes it a habit of drinking every day.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You know?
- [Mark] But you stopped drinking?
- I stopped drinking.
I drink maybe once every,
one beer in one month
or something like that.
I don't even finish it.
- [Mark] That's great.
- Yeah.
I guess when you have so many problems,
you're trying to find a way out (chuckles)
alcohol was one of them.
- [Mark] No, what do you think if your
15 year old son sees this video
and sees that dad's seeing prostitutes.
How would you feel about that?
- I don't know.
I have no idea how, I'll feel like,
I don't know.
I feel like,
a piece of a you know.
(laughing)
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- I feel like a piece of,
what they say, you know shit.(giggles)
- [Mark] Oh. (chuckles)
- But I mean,
eventually the mom,
the mom already build
a lot of things in him?
'Cause we went through a
breakup and you know...
- [Mark] So she's already
told him things that--
- He don't even wanna talk
to me, so I figured that.
- [Mark] Oh really?
- Yeah, I figured that she
already made up so many things
about me that I don't care right now.
Like he don't even wanna talk to me,
I call him, and he don't answer the phone,
I text him.
- [Mark] Oh really?
- Right now I feel like, I don't care
like whatever he knows.
'Cause the mom already probably
told him too many things
about me, you know?
- [Mark] Did that all start
around the divorce time?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Do you ever do any kind of kinkier things,
than just the basics?
- [Juan] Oh yeah.
No.
When I got divorced or is it,
my sex life was really boring.
I knew I wanted to try new things
so yeah, I get kinky,
I play daddy. (laughing)
I role play.
Actually,
I bought a stripping pole
and a stripping pole in my living room,
I'm gonna put up a stripping
pole in the living room
and a swing.
- [Mark] Oh really
- [Juan] in the bedrooms.
That's how kinky I wanna get.
- [Mark] Oh so you're
having fun with the girls?
- [Juan] Yes.
- [Mark] What other kind
of things do you engage in?
- [Juan] Toys, that's it.
- [Mark] These are things
your wife would not really?
- [Juan] No, she wouldn't do any of them.
- [Mark] Do you think you had
these desires even in your marriage?
- [Juan] Yeah, before I got divorced,
I wanted to improve our situation.
and I guess by buying toys
and all but she wouldn't,
she wouldn't do it.
That's one of the reasons
divorce, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- But I mean when you got
when you hunger to learn new things
about improving your sex life,
I guess that's one of them, you know?
- [Mark] Mmhmm.
- Yeah.
You've get cravings in
you that you wanna try,
your partner is not willing to try,
it's not gonna work out.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Do you ever get other people involved,
than just the two of you?
- I mean I thought about threesomes,
a threesome but I mean,
that's something that I
would really think about,
'cause when you're having a threesome
with somebody that you care about
and then involving somebody else,
to me that's not,
that's not right,
Yet, I don't know.
I have that craving to do it,
but I don't wanna compromise
the relationship with that person.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
Even though you're just paying her
and she'll probably do
anything you'd like?
- Probably, I would think
about it like really hard,
but I would,
I do wanna try it but the
moment hasn't come up yet.
- [Mark] Do you find your appetite
or your desires are getting wilder as you?
- Oh yeah definitely.
- [Mark] The older you get.
- I mean definitely.
- [Mark] Or the more
experienced you get maybe?
- I believe I'm a sex addict,
I gotta have it, I gotta have it.
The person, the girl
that I'm with right now,
we spend hours and hours having sex.
Hours, we started at a certain time
and we look at the time
and it's like four hours, six hours.
We do it that long and that much,
that every time it keeps back
getting better and better.
- [Mark] Oh
- Better and better.
There's not one time,
not even one time that
it's been horrible sex.
It's been always good good sex.
I never experienced that before,
never.
It just keeps on getting
better and better.
- [Mark] That would make it hard to go
to a relationship,
with a girl that's not a
professional at this right?.
Your likelihood of finding
that, it could be slim.
- I mean right now
I'm at a point that,
I like how it's going,
I like how it's turning out
and I wouldn't change it, for anything.
- [Mark] Well what would
you say the wildest,
kinkiest thing you've done has been?
- Let's see, for one thing,
we recorded a lot of things that we do,
record and probably,
(laughing)
I guess,
anal sex.
Anal sex would be the kinkiest,
or a butt plug in
and me inside,
I guess.
Is that what they call DP?
- [Mark] Right?
- Yeah, but I mean, as far as it's going,
I think we're gonna be more
creative and more (laughing),
we put porn too, just to get more ideas,
every time, there's porn.
- [Mark] Do you think
this affects your life
outside of the bedroom?
- It hasn't.
- [Mark] Yeah?
- No.
- [Mark] It might even help it, perhaps?
- Yeah, I think it would,
as long as you're with somebody
that's as twisted as
you I guess, it's good.
'Cause if you find like my
ex-wife, she was boring,
then I wanted to experience new things,
it wouldn't...
She thought I was,
she thinks I'm a pervert, just by that.
Who doesn't love sex?
Everybody loves sex.
So I guess I am a pervert (laughing),
and I could be a bigger pervert
with the right person. (laughing)
- [Mark] You found the
right person it sounds like.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- [Mark] All right Juan,
thank you so much for talking with me.
Thank you for being so honest and open.
- Well thank you. (laughs)
- [Mark] Thanks.